Nos piden que simplifiquemos esta
enorme expresión ¿Ok? "x" al cubo más 3x -6 más entre paréntesis
-2x más "x" -2 - entre paréntesis 3x -4
¿Ok? Entonces pues lo que tenemos que hacer es respirar profundo y no pensar que está enorme
e ir paso a paso. Lo primero que vamos a hacer es tratar de deshacernos de estos paréntesis,
aquí tenemos que tener cuidado por que tenemos un - entonces lo vamos a distribuir, entonces pues empecemos.
Aquí tenemos "x" al cubo
"x" al cubo y después tenemos 3x, más 3x
y finalmente - 6 .
Nos deshicimos de este paréntesis por que realmente no le está haciendo nada a estos términos.
Así es que vamos con el siguiente. Del siguiente
paréntesis pues, este más no le está haciendo nada al paréntesis, así es que también podemos simplemente quitarlo y lo que nos queda es
-2x al cuadrado más "x"  y finalmente -2.
Ahora aquí tenemos - y todo el paréntesis, o sea que estamos restando
todos los términos que estén adentro del paréntesis. De hecho podemos pensar que aquí le estamos poniendo un -1
y estamos multiplicando
este -1 por este paréntesis y entonces tenemos que usar la propiedad
distributiva y lo que nos queda es -1 por 3x que es -3x
más -1 por -4 que es simplemente más 4
¿Ok? Entonces llega la hora de agrupar los términos.
Entonces buscamos en toda esta expresión, el término que tenga una "x" con el grado más grande. Está x
cuyo grado es 3 por que es "x" al cubo y entonces vamos a buscar si hay alguna otra "x" al cubo.
No este es el único término de grado 3.
Así es que agrupando todos los términos de grado 3 nos queda simplemente
"x" al cubo.
Entonces vamos a buscar y agrupar todos los términos de grado 2.
¿Ok? Aquí tenemos 1
y listo es el único término así es que por aquí nos queda -2x cuadrada
y ahora vamos a buscar y agrupar todos los términos de grado 1 por aquí tenemos 1.
Éste no, aquí está otro y este es el último.
¿Ok? Entonces nos queda 3x más "x" -3x,
así es que éste se va a cancelar con este por que 3x -3x
pues es 0, y entonces simplemente nos queda más "x" más "x" y
finalmente tenemos que agrupar los términos que no tengan "x" o sea este término con este término.
¡Hey! Espera se me estaba olvidando, no me fijé que aquí había otro término que no tenía "x"
aunque no les debe de pasar eso pero bueno aquí tenemos -6 más
-2 eso es -8
más 4 o sea que tenemos - 4
- 4 y listo hemos terminado de simplificar toda esta expresión
gigantesca y nos quedaron nada más cuatro términos.